♪♪
-Questlove, do you want to
explain how the game works?
[ Laughter ]
-Of course, Jimmy.
In this game,
I will read each of you...
[ Laughter ]
...a mind-blowing fact.
And you must decide
if a fact is true or false.
If you choose wrong,
we will blow your mind.
And you will be
blasted in the face
from the tube in front of you.
Make the right choice and your
opponent gets their mind blown.
-Gotcha, gotcha.
-The first fact is for Steve.
-Jimmy, I can't see.
-True or false...
[ Laughter ]
-The obvious answer --
This is not my final answer,
but the obvious answer
is that it does not,
because it's too silly.
But the fact is --
[ Laughter ]
It's prob-- It's probably true.
I'm going to go with true.
-That's your answer, Steve?
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
I thought it was my turn.
It's your turn. You answer.
-I can't see!
-Steve can't see.
Steve can't see.
-I can't see
if it's my turn or not.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no. Oh, no.
-Yes, yes, that is my answer.
-No, no, it's not true.
It's not true, no.
No. It's false.
-The answer may surprise you.
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's true.
Can we see that again
in slow motion?
[ Laughter ]
Now, the next fact
is for you, Jimmy.
Jimmy.
-Yeah?
-Some turtles can breathe
through their butts.
Truth or lie?
-[ Laughs ]
Now, some turtles can breathe
through their butts?
-Their butts.
-Is this mine now?
-No, it's mine, but I just --
I feel like if I say it --
If I say it, I'm going to sound
like a fool, if it's wrong.
-There's nothing that could make
you look like a fool right now.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I am gonna say --
-Is my mustache still on?
[ Laughter ]
-It's falling --
It's falling off.
It's falling off on this side,
this side.
-I can't tell. I can't see!
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to say yeah.
True, some turtles can breathe
through their butts.
-The answer may surprise you.
-It may surprise me.
♪♪
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes. That's true.
Let's see that again
in slow motion.
-I want to see it
[ Laughter ]
What was that?
What was that, garbage? Garbage?
-Steve, you're up next.
Steve, fact or fiction.
[ Laughter ]
Steve, pay attention.
Thank you.
Cotton candy was invented
by a dentist.
True or false?
-Cotton candy was invented
by a dentist.
-Steve.
[ Laughter ]
-What? I just -- I'm helping him
out with the game.
[ Laughter ]
-Steve, what is your answer?
-Fact! Cotton candy was invented
by a --
-You don't have to yell -- You
don't have to yell the answer.
-Oh, okay. All right.
I thought this was a microphone.
-No, it's not a microphone.
[ Laughter ]
-I thought all the audience had
tubes just like this.
Hello!
Yes, cotton candy was invented
by a dentist.
-The answer may surprise you.
-May surprise you, yes.
♪♪
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, it's true.
Can we see that again
in slow motion, please?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-Jimmy,
the next fact is for you.
-Okeydoke.
-A town in Finland once elected
a reindeer to be their mayor.
Truth or a lie?
-A town in Finland elected
a reindeer to be mayor.
I think it's so crazy
that it's tr-- that it's true.
I'm going to say truth.
-Truth.
The answer --
-May surprise you.
-How did you know?
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-That is a lie.
Let's see that again
in slow motion.
-Oh, my goodness.
What was that you shot at me?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God, okay.
[ Thunder crashes ]
-Excuse me.
-High production value here
at "The Tonight Show."
-That sound means it's time
for the final question.
It's a simple
yes or no question.
-Yep.
-And it comes with a twist.
If you answer incorrectly,
both of you [Echoing]
will have your minds blown.
-Is that the first time there
was an echo in your voice?
[ Laughter ]
-Steve,
the question goes to you.
-I'm -- I'm ready.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. Your mustache is on your
lower lip somehow.
I've never seen -- I've never
seen anything like that.
It's like a beard mustache.
-Yes, true.
-Wait, wait.
-Let me ask the question first.
-Oh, I thought you meant
about the mustache.
-No, yeah, no.
-Is a thumb a finger?
True or false?
Is a thumb a finger?
-A thumb is not a finger.
-A thumb...is a thumb.
-But we have five fingers,
right?
How many fingers do you have?
-Four fingers and a thumb.
-You've never said
that ever in your lifetime.
-You haven't heard
the old adage?
Four fingers and a thumb ago
makes Jack healthy,
wealthy, and wise.
-That is not a statement.
-The answer may surprise you.
-Oh, God.
♪♪
-The thumb is a finger.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
-You are wrong.
Let's see that again
in slow motion.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
There you go right there.
The winner -- Steve Carell.
[ Cheers and applause ]